اعلنت وزاره الثقافه السعوديه استقطاب
اكثر من 240 الف مشاركه من المدارس في اول
نسخ مسابقه المهارات الثقافيه التي
اطلقتها الوزاره بالتنسيق مع وزاره
التعليم المسابقه الثقافيه السعوديه تتضمن
سبع محطات بدءا من اكتشاف المبدعين وصولا
الى عمليه تدريبهم من خلال برنامج تفاعليا
شامل لرفع كفاءه المشاركات الابداعيه
وتنافس المشاركين على جوائز تصل الى خمسه
ملايين ريال
تنضم الينا من الرياض قطان وكيله وزاره
الثقافه للشركات الوطنيه والتطويريه
سيد انواع حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض وخلينا نسال اولا يعني 247 الف
هذا عدد كبير في اول نسخه هل كان هذا
المستهدف من البدايه
اهلين سعيد جدا بهذه الاستضافه وبالفعل هو
العدد اكبر من ما كنا يعني نستهدف
كمقارنه بالمسابقات الاخرى بنفس هذا
المجال او حتى في دول اخرى كان يمكن
المستهدف ما يتراوح بين 20 الى 40 الف
مشاركه واليوم احنا اضعاف هذا المشاركات
الحمد لله دعم القياده بتوجيهاتها اكيد
ممتازه نساله ايضا عن هالمسابقه لماذا هذه
المسابقه
وايش المحطات اللي يمر فيها المشاركين
ايضا في هذه المسابقه النتيجه معروفه هي
جوائز لكن ابغى اسال عن البدايه عن هذه
المسابقه ليش موجوده وايش المحطات اللي
موجوده فيها ايضا كذلك
هذه المسابقه احدى المبا
درات التي يتم الثقافيه اللي نتجت عن
الشراكه بين وزاره التعليم وزاره الثقافه
وهدف ما احد يحاول هذه الاستراتيجيه بشكل
كبير واكتشاف المواهب ليس فقط الهدف
الجوائز لكن فعلا اكتشاف هذه المواهب
صقلها وتنميتها وصولها الى مستوى محترف او
مستوى متطور
فهذا يمكن بدايه المسابقه وفكرتها وكانت
ايضا فكره ان احنا نبدا اكتشف الميدان
بدخول هذه المجالات الثقافيه الجديده على
التعليم يمكن ما كانت موجوده سابقا اليوم
عندنا سته محاور مختلفه في المسابقه ضمنها
التراث المسرح الموسيقى الادب الافلام
الفنون البصريه
ما هي كلها موجوده في ضمن مناهج التعليميه
او يومنا التعليم
صحيح في برنامج تفاعلي ايضا موجود في هذه
في هذه المسابقه والفعاليه التي تنظمونها
بالتعاون مع وزاره التعليم اللي هو
البرنامج التفاعلي وشو ممكن نعرف عنها
البرنامج
الفكره بالفعل
محطات او عدد من محطات اللي موجوده ضمن
المسابقه واحدا هي بعد اكتشاف المرحله
الاولى وفرز المشاركات البدء بعمل دورات
تدريبيه مختلفه للمسارات حقت المسابقه
وهذه تسمح لنا نحن ناخذ هذه المهارات ولو
بشكل مبدئي ونبدا نطورها لمشاركه جديده
نبدا نصفي فيها التصفيه الاولى لمشاركات
اكثر احترا فيه ففكره التدريب في عدد من
الخبراء والمختصين اللي نتعامل معاهم في
كل مجال من مجالات
ونبدا يعني تعتبر جزء منها اكتشاف هذه
المواهب وجزء منها تنميتها او التدريب
بشكل اكبر عليها
طيب انت ذكرتي المجالات اللي يركز عليها
او تركز على هذه المسابقه يعني مجالات
كلها مختصه في مجالات يعني ثقافيه او
موسيقيه وفيها فنون ايضا كذلك لكن خليني
اسال بعد مرحله الفارز ومرحله ايضا حتى
حصول المتسابقين فيها على الجوائز
المشاركين من هذه الوزاره هل ستدخلونهم في
برامج ممكن يكون مستقبل في برامج ابتعاث
لهم او تنميه هذه المهارات
بالفعل
يمكن جزئين من الجو
ائز فيها وفي
مجال الجوائز العينيه وجوائز العينيه
تختلف اما من اجهزه او الات او نوع من
التدريب اللي ممكن يحصل عليه الفائز
لتنميه هذه المهاره او حتى الدخول في مجال
الابتعاد او
تبني لهذه المواهب واستمراريتها مع
الوزاره بدعم مستمر والعمل عليها اشكرك
جزيل الشكر بالتوفيق لكم ان شاء الله من
الرياض قطان وكيله وزاره الثقافه للشركات
الوطنيه والتطوير شكرا جزيلا لك